Ellen DeGeneres pokes fun at the
kardashian baby boom this season all the
Kardashians are having babies or we like
to call them spin-offs
[Music]
in honor of Halloween the talk show host
brought back her keeping up character
the lesser-known Kardashian's sister
Carla and I've got a new baby bump under
my lady lumps the generous poked fun at
the famous family's multiple pregnancies
Kim recently confirmed she's expecting
her third child with Kanye West to be a
surrogate and sources tell et that Khloe
is pregnant with her first child with
NBA boyfriend Tristan Thompson while
Kylie Jenner is expecting with rapper Bo
Travis Scott but I have breaking news
and I'm not supposed to tell anybody but
I don't care because I'm a part of the
family
Kourtney is also pregnant as well but
Kourt was on hand to shut that down I'm
not pregnant the reality stars little
sis kendall Jenner also showed up
assuring viewers that she's not
expecting either you gotta chill cuz I'm
not but you have to jail is what do you
do okay